from the very very beginning of any
project now like i'm
one of my first thoughts is who is the
audience for this and where do i find
them
jay you have a video that you did maybe
a year or so ago entitled top five
reasons your indie film is failing yeah
and so we took the liberty of writing
down your excellent tips and we're
hoping to have you read them maybe we
could start with five first okay yeah so
five reasons your indie film is failing
number five you are pushing your movie
in all the wrong places um so this is
what i'm talking about here is
when you have you know a certain
genre of film like you need to
specifically find that audience right
and i find a lot of people what i see
over and over like when i wrote this
comment i was specifically thinking
about filmmakers that were promoting
their movies and filmmaking groups
because like you'll see this all the
time like you have all these filmmaking
groups and they're like hey go check out
my movie to all the other filmmakers and
the filmmakers aren't necessarily your
target audience if your movie is about
filmmaking
maybe that's right but for the most part
like no that's don't promote there you
know like that's not filmmakers are not
going to drive that the viewership you
know um or
you know you know people shotgun out
their promotion so you know they're like
let's let's do the exact same post on
facebook because on twitter has on
instagram as on linkedin and all of
these social media platforms are very
different in the type of material that
gets traction you know so like
for example you know like on the
documentaries um i like i do very well
promoting on facebook in facebook groups
that are specific to that subject matter
um and on uh twitter like twitter with
hashtags that are targeted towards that
target audience but like you know
linkedin
kind of okay for documentaries but not
so much but like you you should
concentrate on
what you're comfortable with you know
like for example i've spent the most
time on facebook so like i'm pretty good
at writing a post that's going to engage
people on facebook so that's where i
concentrate a lot of my promotion you
know and you know like like i'm not as
good at twitter so i don't concentrate
on twitter as much i'll put post there
but i don't spend an overt amount of
time on it
but um and i don't uh like or i
discovered uh pinterest a lot of people
say like pinterest is you know
a waste of time but like i've gotten a
lot of really good video views there you
know so i find just you know keep your
keep your promotion
you know targeted to the right audience
you know it's number five
what about a subreddit let's suppose
your documentary is on
something that's medical related or
whatever if there was a subreddit on
that subscribe on that yeah what i've
found with reddit so i do do a little
promotion on reddit but i i find in
general uh reddit's not great for direct
promotion like you have to be really sly
with your promotion on reddit because
there are
like some facebook groups there's rules
but like facebook it's it's really easy
to circumvent them like reddit you know
i've had i've been banned from many
threads you know for you know throwing a
link in something like you have to
engage with people on a more personal
level there
and
by doing that sometimes you can get some
interest in your stuff but just like
direct promotion i i've not had much
luck
sure there's too many people that are
yeah ready to come at you yeah that
makes sense
okay number four number four you've
picked too broad of you've picked too
broad of a genre so this is like like
you know i'm making a horror movie right
and like that's it that's your genre
that's who you're targeting horror is a
super broad i'm not saying don't do a
horror movie but i'm saying
there are sub genres of horror so what
is your sub genre are you a monster
movie or is it a siege movie is it a
combination of the two you know what i'm
finding recently is that you know
amalgamations and you know combining
sub-genres is really cool you know so
like you know the movie i'm getting
ready to do it's a monster movie but
it's also a siege picture you know it
has a little bit of a crime element to
it and you know pinching those together
but when people are just like i'm making
a drama
where do you promote a drama you know
where do you promote a general drama
movie now what's that drama about
is it about a small business owner what
type of business is that owner own is
there a community around that kind of
small business like you don't
necessarily have to you know create a
project around your your marketing like
hey i'm going to create this like double
sub genre no you're making a drama movie
but
you don't think of it in general terms
you think of it in specific terms you
know what what what's the race of the
people is this or is this people of
color is it lgbtq or is it just is it
white folk you know and who are you
marketing to from the beginning so like
i find narrowing that down really early
on and knowing what your project is and
how to get to those people is how you
market successfully an indie film
okay let's suppose
it's a mumble core
college film
um
early 20s relationship movie
so i would the first
first thing i would do is look at you
know so
if they're straight or the sexual
orientation i would look at that um you
would be you if you're doing a drama
movie these days
my
piece of advice is find an underserved
market not to exploit it but to shine
light
on it to you know because you know one
one one subgenre that's doing really
well like on 2b these days is um you
know like a black based uh female
focused like romance
with you know maybe a slight crime tinge
to it and like you know 10 years ago
those movies were flown you couldn't you
couldn't make hardly anything on them
now they're they're doing really well
because it's an underserved market you
know so or you know if your mumblecore
thing is it about is the main character
a musician
um let's just say they're a musician so
what type of music is it
target those types of fans you know or
if they're a baker what kind of baker is
it what kind of cook or culinary skill
you know
find find things in the movie that are a
strong enough element in the movie that
you can market around it like to garner
interest because it's really the biggest
mistake i see filmmakers making over and
over with their marketing is they're
it's just it's so general i'm i'm making
i just made this drama movie and here it
is here's my trailer
you have to give people a little bit
more than that you know there has to be
something that they can connect to that
they're gonna
have interest in that post to even
engage with it you know
great point that's very true
okay number three
your overall marketing is ineffective so
um
i i honestly don't remember exactly what
i was saying with that one but i think
what i was getting at is uh
like you're you're just being too
like generic in your marketing you're
like here like here's my movie check it
out you know how many filmmakers do you
see on social media here's my movie
check it out let me know what you think
like who who who does that except for
like your very like good friends or your
mom who who is going to comment on that
you know unless it's to just tear you
down and you know
chastise you for making a generic post
um so that in general i think people
look at marketing like they just don't
understand that it's about engaging
people about getting their interest
about intriguing them asking a question
like you'll see over and over on my
posts like i'll promote my youtube
channel a lot in filmmaking groups but i
always phrase all of my posts has a
question you know if i do a video about
um you know how to how to distribute an
indie film you know my question will be
what are some of your experiences
distributing your independent films
here's mine you know and that will
create engagement or if it's uh you know
say you're doing a comedy movie
um about a uh about a startup you know
and you're going to start into some
startup groups and you're like what
what are some what are some of the
challenges that you had starting up like
your startup right and you start getting
some and you don't even post about the
movie and you start getting some
comments on that and then within there
you start dropping in like oh i just you
know i did this movie about it here it
is you know
and that is another way to gain some
engagement in some of those groups sure
and then it turns out you made silicon
valley yeah yeah yeah and you make and
you make you make friends this way it's
like networking i mean you know going
back to uh you know like crowdfunding
like that's all about
you know connecting with people you know
it's not everybody says it's about
asking for money it's not about asking
for money it's about connecting with
people and and you are giving them
something for their money whether that's
directly you know
roi worth it is you know a different
story but you know you are you are
providing something that they want
right and with each update you know you
get to root as a group for the project
totally number two is my favorite
um you didn't think about the audience
before making it you made the film for
you and not them yeah this is my this is
like my my mantra this has become my
mantra like over the last probably four
years
like i when i started my career
i made movies that i wanted to make and
absolutely no thought of of
where is this going to play
who is the audience for it
who's going to watch it how much are
they going gonna pay for it like what
what's it gonna do i'm just i just wanna
make this because this is what i wanna
do and i think a lot of filmmakers start
with this mindset and i'm not
i'm not saying that this is like an evil
mindset i'm saying you you have to
balance it with a
with a marketing mind like the the days
of you know a filmmaker you know like uh
you know richard linklater one of them
coming in doing a movie and just blowing
up like i'm not saying it never happens
but it's happening less and less and
less you know so like when we make a
movie we do got to think about
who is who is this for even at the very
beginning when you're writing the script
like like who is this for
what is the genre what is the sub genre
what are elements within that genre that
people are looking for and i'm not
talking about doing a like cookie cutter
list and hitting all those points in
your movie sometimes you subvert those
expectations but you have to be aware of
it you know like what do they want and
if you don't give it to them
are they going to engage with your movie
you know
so
from from the very very beginning of any
project now like i'm
one of my first thoughts is who is the
audience for this and where do i find
them because if you have no clue
then you either need to go back to the
drawing board or like reverse engineer
you know your marketing early to to
figure it out you know if you're doing a
horror movie you know you're doing a
a horror movie siege pitcher you know
with uh with a hispanic cast you know
and you don't know where to find your
audience you need to start thinking
about where to find your audience as
soon as possible
who do you think slacker was for at that
time
i think slacker at that time was 4
18 it was for gen x you know young
um artists
you know of
i mean like i wanted to be a filmmaker
and i was into it but there there was
just there was
i think it really spoke to that
generation
you know and if if i was doing something
like that now like slacker
um i would definitely be targeting like
i would target some filmmaking groups
for that movie you know because because
it is but i would also be looking
outside that musician's artist you know
it had her there was uh
one of them was a poet it's been so long
since i've seen it but you know the
different characters were
in a lot of different you know
up-and-coming low income you know there
wasn't a lot of rich characters in that
so like i would be looking at
you know like and that's another thing
like if you're doing targeted ads on
facebook for example like you can kind
of you can target by
you know education level and by
income you know as much as as much info
as they have you know and i think that
those things are are important sure and
a lot of conspiracy theory talk too was
in that film which oh yeah yeah yeah
that's another i totally forgot about
that actually yeah the conspiracy theory
and there's so many conspiracy things
right now like right now if actually
that would be so it right now is just
off the cuff like uh
advice like you you want to do a little
like drama movie something like that
have some character that's super into
conspiracy theories and tie them
directly into some stuff that's going on
and you will
you will have people to push that as
long as you
like if you're doing something like that
like don't make fun of them you know
don't exploit them like like even if you
don't believe it or you think it's total
bull like let them have their voice you
know that way like that audience won't
completely turn on you you know i mean
of course you do that within you know
your own moral boundaries don't you know
broadcast something that you don't you
know believe in or you thinks are moral
but if it's not then you know go for it
great and last but not least number one
yeah yeah the number one reason that
the indie films don't make money is it's
just not good and and i'm not saying
that all indie films are not good here
but and i'm not saying that it's always
the reason but
we have to be honest with ourselves when
a movie finishes when we like we finish
it it's in the can we got it edited
how did it turn out you know like how
far is this movie gonna go you know like
how much effort do i put into it and i'm
not saying just a man in your movie and
forget it if it doesn't turn out like i
i fully believe you should release
everything you make like release it put
it out you know
um even if you put it out under another
name put it out you know like i i have
never not finished a movie and i i don't
have a lot of
i don't have a lot of sympathy for
people that finish something and don't
put it out you know like like cl they're
put it out there's so much effort that
went into it there are people there are
people that want it to be seen like get
it out there but i think what happens
most of the time is filmmakers just
don't have
the the distance or the i don't know the
maturity or you know hindsight to say
hey you know this
didn't turn out exactly how i wanted it
you know so they think
it's their perfect baby but maybe it's
not you know or or maybe it is good but
it's
just because you make a good movie or a
fine enough movie it's not entitled to
make money
you know like no no platform owes you
for it to perform you know the audience
doesn't owe you to watch it you have to
you have to get them in and if you fail
at that
that's that's it it's not going to
perform you know and sometimes i think a
lot of movies come into the market and
people haven't
paid attention to the other four things
and you know maybe technically the movie
is fine you know like like it looks good
it's in focus it's got you know good
production value performances are okay
but they ignored the audience they made
their little personal film and it has it
didn't deliver anything
that an audience wants or needs and it
it doesn't do well
i think number one would be the toughest
to really be honest about with yourself
because you know there's kind of two
camps of people one everything they do
is amazing and two everything they do
they think is crap yeah and i think both
people are going to have a hard time
seeing their film for what it is it is
you're 100 right and i and i sat here
and i just you know went on this whole
spiel about it but i myself struggled
with that for a long time you know i
made you know when i made rise of the
undead my first movie and i you know
i'll say it right here the movie is not
good you know and but it it took me a
few years to to be able to to see it
you know because like i was always
rationalizing it well this is cool or
this worked or you know and then you
know it's not doing well it's not
resonating i'm like why why why you know
it said eventually
i ca
i think about two years
like of it being out i was you know i
was able to sit down and really say you
know what this this wasn't good and then
why wasn't it good and honestly like it
you know it wasn't the wasn't the image
it wasn't the sound it wasn't the
performances
i didn't spend enough time on the story
and on the script you know we made that
first movie and wrote that script to
have something to shoot you know and
two years later when i'm like why is
this not great
i didn't spend enough time on the script
so
after that i became really immersed in
like like screenwriting and writing and
for a long time if you would ask me i
would say i'm a writer first and you
know then a director and i think that's
when my stuff started getting a little
bit better and this was in 2003
yeah that's when we shot it we shot that
in 2003 it came out in 2005 and uh so it
was probably like 2006 or seven where i
was like yeah it's not so great
and it took me about a year to edit that
movie it was my very first i mean i
basically learned how to edit doing that
movie